und jetzt kann ich euch sagen dass der
community ist soweit fertig ist die ip
zum tee es ist übrigens ganz ganz
schlicht und einfach zu merken servus s
kids was geht bei euch herzlich über zu
einem neuen npd und wir spielen heute
wie ganz klar zu erkennen ist der blick
auf play.com und es gibt was zu
berichten
ich habe mich jetzt endlich mal bisschen
zeit gehabt ihr wisst ihr ich hatte
bisher bisschen was zu tun in der uni
aber jetzt habe ich ein bisschen zeit
und konnte mich um meine sachen kümmern
die schon länger an stand damals schon
viele von euch sehr oft gefragt und
pipapo hier und wo man kommt da ist dann
kommt dies stets damit und jetzt ist
zumindest mal dieser eine große punkt
von den drei großen punkten die ich mir
sozusagen gesetzt habe er ist eigentlich
mehr es sind 4 5 kanal aber auf jeden
fall mutter meine liebe wird der punkt
ist auf jeden fall gewesen bzw
die drei die metzger spontan einfallen
das war einmal der server einmal der
community ts und dann die t-shirts und
jetzt kann ich euch sagen dass der
community ist soweit fertig ist
der ist komplett eingerichtet und der
link dazu
den kann ich euch natürlich auch gleich
mal verraten
kommissar batic kommen er musste es mehr
konzentrieren so 123 ja da hat mich
übrigens ganz hatte ich ja jetzt kann
ich nochmal ansprechen so eins nach dem
anderen gedanken ordnen schwierig ich
hatte der mich da unterstützung von dem
team von prepaid hoster die haben mir
den teamspeak server und den server
gesponsert sind auch ab jetzt in einer
beschreibung verlinkt wenn ihr mal auf
deren homepage gehen wollt solltet lust
habt schaut einfach danach
vielen dank an euch sehr sehr cool
und dank denen kann ich jetzt auch
offiziell verkünden dass der teamspeak
freigeschaltet ist und die da drauf
gehen könnte er ist soweit auch
eingerichtet
ich hab heute wieder mich etwas
verspätet mit dem video beziehungsweise
ich habe eigentlich keinen termin um
pünktlich zu sein aber ich habe heute
den ganzen tag an beim referat gesetzt
und werde auch noch weiter im referat zu
haben jetzt halb sieben
ich bin seit na ja sagt pommer seit 11
uhr bin ich dran an dem referat jetzt
habe ich eine kurze pause gemacht für
das video für heute so
nachher geht ja weiter dran das muss ich
morgen um 10 uhr in der uni halten
ihr könnt ja wenn ihr morgens 10 dran
denken wir die daumen drücken
dann wird eure spirituelle energie
übertragen
warum zählen das referat wie gesagt ist
alten mega geiles thema das habe ich
heute erst bemerkt so wirklich hat mich
erst heute richtig damit
auseinandergesetzt
weil ich gestern noch besucht hatte und
sagte hier alles gut ok hat gereicht so
heißt ja dadurch erst gestern zeit ich
habe am freitagabend mich schon mal kurz
drangesetzt aber auch nach dem 12 und
mit
in einem zustand wo ich besonders
aufnahmefähig war ich erzähle euch
erstmal ganz frei von der leber erzählt
mann bzw schreiben hier mal in den
kommentaren was ihr davon haltet
wenn ich einfach mal so ganz sinnbefreit
aushang walter berichte und ja ich hätte
heute eigentlich ganz schwieriger
sonntag ich konnte endlich mal
ausschlafen
ich habe davor wirklich wirklich lange
nicht ausgeschlafen weil einfach immer
irgendwas war die seltsamsten gründe
aber gut jetzt habe ich mal geschafft
sehr schön danke theorie ja das war okay
wir finden es soweit und jetzt zerreisst
kritik ist wahr wir schlecht aber egal
das passt sowohl ist jetzt lange ich
spiele dieses modul gerade zum ersten
mal oder
ich hoffe ihr es nicht irgendwann ganz
gemeine falle die kost sein er will ford
in twitter wo geht's hier weiter da
hinten oder überhaupt kommt von da unten
steht dann geht's da drüben weiter
wahrscheinlich ihr okay alles klar alles
klar
alles gut
was nein als ob nun ein ich hab das team
verpasst abschied aus steht wer bin ich
eigentlich ich glaube ich bin wohl
fühlen kann es seien weder drüben egal
passt so kommt zack gut hier drüben die
leiter ist ein bisschen schwierig immer
sowas zum ersten mal sieht
ach ja heute bevor es vor checke die ip
zum tee es ist übrigens ganz ganz
schlicht und einfach zu merken es pay tv
nein jetzt guck ich einmal kurzen die
face kärlich direkt unter escape tv oder
könnt ihr gerne drauf john ab jetzt wird
jetzt der community ts seien für längere
zeit weil ich diesmal in seriösen
sponsor hat er da auch nicht
irgendwelchen komischen personen mod
richtige die dann wieder um meine leute
abfangen
aber das ist eine andere geschichte
manches mal kennen die vielleicht für
die anderen diese nicht kennen
es war einfach uncool so lasst euch
niemals server von leuten sponsoren die
ihr nicht wirklich einschätzen können
aber wohl nicht wirklich sagen könnt ihr
auf dem server rechte hat weil da gibt's
dann leute die mich brauchen das rohgold
alter vor kopfschmerzen
ich habe gerade eben meine küche so ein
bisschen gibt kurz mit zum klo reiniger
unterricht einfach derbe nach hallenbad
und ich habe das gefühl es hat mich ein
bisschen mitgenommen so auf kohle ist
schon ziel was ja aber nicht okay krasse
sache ist auch schon im ziel
na gut dann machen das jetzt her wir
sehen ihren kopf gefallen das klingt
vielleicht auch so her mit der angel der
hier jobs war im team gewinnt im golf
sodann haben also mal erwischt dirigent
ist drehen alles klar
darüber ist nicht aber es müsse stärker
verstecken oh gott oh gott wie viele
jo-jo kurz mal gucken was man hier
irgendwann wieder bekommen kann
nice schön zwei kids bekommt tatsächlich
sehr eschborn ots unten ich habe es
gelesen dass die leute meinen ich würde
so mega oft bloß sagen und ich glaube
stimmt sogar das bistum einen standard
wort jeder so dazu paar worte die
einfach immer ein baum kehrpflicht
gezuckerte gerecht oder für den kika die
abwehr zwar lebe noch zu erleben
der typ der innenstadt hat braucht nur
noch zwei lebenswert gegenseitig getötet
egal ob in falkenstein schritt für mich
ist es gibt ein stein schwert für den ok
wie geht es weiter
seht ihr einfach dranbleiben blick
einfach immer dranbleiben ein bisschen
faul ok krass hat er gewartet mit dem
bau heftiger typ auf jeden fall kann ich
jetzt viel zusammen bringen euch beide
gebäude sich immer besser kennen lernen
oder red rain that fucking range neu
erfasst wie die einfach thema der
schießt auf wie ich was
was war das alter oder ok vielleicht
haben sie auch nicht getarnt aber dass
das sehr seltsam aus das war wirklich
sehr sehr seltsam aus komm lass dich
wegholen auch illegal fester den bogen
in der kasse gehabt oder irgendwie
besseres equipment etwas mitnehmen kann
ja da war bogen drin nice nice links
rechts kommen bisserl und wer mir geholt
heutiger das war knapp es war unser
letztes lebendes rauskommen können
ja leute ansonsten ist bei mir heute ein
relativ verzierter tag den ganzen tag
übel verdient obwohl ich eigentlich
genug schlafen bekommt der kombi
zusammen
er besteht noch mal jetzt prospekt muss
man abbauen müssen wir abbauen aber er
geht nicht in die kiste dass es dumm ich
weiß es nicht
auf jeden fall müssten wir jetzt abbauen
wir mussten ok jetzt gehen wir zurück
und gucken dass wir da um den stoff aus
der kiste bekommen nicht dass der demo
kommt dass wir ein bisschen krake paul
hat ihn schon bekommen als jetzt ein
problem hat einfach alles rausholen
können sowie knapp diese runde einfach
immer ist
alter schwede diese roten darangemacht
locker jetzt zweimal wirklich so knapp
davor auszuscheiden
einfach weil ich bisher steht der darum
flemings die schauen wir mal
besucher waren steve der in seinem
keller stevens ich glaube hier geht's
runter positiv da bist du siehst wie
steve brulé supplies wow was für eine
entscheidung
das ist wahrscheinlich das
wahrscheinlich das schwierigste gegner
der schwierigste letzte kill den ich
jemals hatte
er ist einfach afk und gar auf zack zack
kann ich in fünf bitte lass
unfallschaden sterben noch nicht
gereicht schicken da muss mal nachgeben
egal es war eine sehr sehr gute runde
aber ganz davon abgesehen dass der typ
es am ende wirklich nicht so der
härtesten challenge war aber es hat mir
gut gefallen leute der link zum
teamspeak ist natürlich auch unten in
der beschreibung und schreibt einfach
mal in die kommentare
was euch jetzt zu dem thema so einfällt
habt ihr schon in welche pläne was er
auf den teams mitmachen wollt wollt ihr
euch wäscheklammern ans ohr stecken so
wie ich oder irgendwie nach heiraten ich
weiß es nicht keine ahnung ich jetzt
behauptet laster von daumen nach oben
nahm er sich gefallen und wir sehen uns
wieder macht gut und